you
flow go with the flow it's not just an
expression it's a powerful way of living
it'll make you a better entrepreneur and
a better person when you try to force
something you don't get amazing results
on monday night I had an idea for my
business so I did what I usually do i
emailed myself the idea so I wouldn't
forget it and I continue with my day
after all it was past midnight and I
should be getting ready for bed but I
was feeling this idea I worried that if
I tackled it tomorrow I wouldn't have
the same energy or enthusiasm for it the
next steps wouldn't be as clear as they
were to me right now because i was in
flow so i pushed off bedtime sat back
down on my laptop and got to work and it
was great i finished the whole plan
drafted two documents and recorded two
videos i looked up and it was two thirty
in the morning I didn't even know where
the time went but I managed to do in two
and a half hours what normally would
have taken me two days the end product
was also better than it would have been
if I worked on it the next day it had
more passion it was something special
because it was created when I was in
flow pay attention to your flow I have
one of the most structured schedules of
anyone I know on Mondays i right on
Wednesdays I do videos on thursdays i
take meetings my days are split up into
one and a half hour chunks of time and
everything is accounted for unless i get
into flow flow changes everything when I
get into a state of flow I keep working
I blow through deadlines I push off
other responsibilities because what you
create when you're in flow is so
incredibly valuable that everything else
is secondary flow is rare flows a funny
thing you can have it for an hour or for
the whole day just like a baseball
hitter who's on a hot streak you can be
in flow for weeks but it'll disappear as
quickly as it came and you feel like
you're in a slump unsure what to do next
not motivated by your business anymore
forcing yourself to keep going capture
your flow so when flow does come to you
you
have to run with it it's critical it'll
help you make amazing things truly
wonderful special things what are you
worried about the other projects that
you have to do are slowly killing you
nothing impactful will ever come from
them so when flow comes right the way
for as long as you can you owe it to
yourself and your community believe